the Republican replacement to Obamacare
is dead yet again another major failure
on the growing list of embarrassing and
pathetic failures for both Donald Trump
and Republicans dozens of House votes to
repeal Obamacare under President Obama
when of course there was no chance that
it would actually be repealed a year of
campaigning by Donald Trump and
Republicans on repeal and put in a
beautiful system that would happen right
away and fail failure after failure this
is the second or fourth failure
depending on how you're sort of counting
them Mitch McConnell wanted this done
before the fourth of July that didn't
happen then he wanted it done before the
August break and it is dead once again
and why is it dead it has nothing to do
with Democrats it is because Republicans
who realize that legislating is tougher
than campaign rhetoric have decided at
least a few of them not to support this
thing Republicans Mike Lee and Jerry
Moran joined up with Rand Paul and Susan
Collins to oppose the bill and then the
math just made it impossible to even
start debate on the bill and the math is
simple enough where even maybe Donald
Trump could understand it when you have
52 Republicans and four of them won't
vote for it you can't get to 50% it's
the simplest of math and why is this
happening because you can't move to the
right from the Affordable Care Act and
improve our health care situation you
can't increase access and reduce cost
when you go from Obamacare to the right
now that being said the Republicans that
oppose the bill in the Senate mostly
oppose it for the wrong reasons senator
Morgan is against it because it only
partially repeals Obamacare fine I mean
I agree with opposing the bill but
that's not really a great reason to
oppose it senator Lee said that the bill
doesn't go far enough in lowering
premiums for middle class families and
it's not separate enough from Obamacare
Rand Paul is similar he said the bill is
basically Obamacare plus in some areas
so I can't support it and Susan Collins
had sort of the most reasonable reason
which
she wants to see a CBO analysis that's
not as bad as the one that they got what
about seeing a CBO analysis that's good
like why would you why would she support
it if it was a less bad CBO analysis but
anyway I'm glad that they're not
supporting and really that list of
Senate Republicans who oppose this bill
was more than four those were just the
four that came out publicly right it was
probably something like ten or fifteen
and I'm just confused because I remember
after the House passed their version of
this bill Donald Trump had that big Rose
Garden all that rage and he even said
that if the Senate couldn't pass the
American Health Care Act that they would
look like dopes and they do obviously
now the question about whether they'll
be held accountable for that dope
business is a different one we'll talk
about that later what options exist now
they could try again for another repeal
and replace bill they could acquiesce to
keep Obamacare but make changes with
Democrats to fix it
or they could try to just get a straight
Obamacare repeal and then try to deal
with a replacement later which Donald
Trump is mentioned now a couple of times
now working with Dems to quote fix
Obamacare is risky in a few ways one is
the ways that Republicans want to fix
the Affordable Care Act are actually a
disaster everybody likes the provisions
of the Affordable Care Act but not
everybody likes the mandates and the
taxes and you need the mandates and the
taxes in order to pay for the stuff that
people do like and it's also risky
politically because if you do negotiate
some improvements to the Affordable Care
Act you then risk the political
implication implications of allowing
Republicans to say hey we improved
Obamacare which would really be a
drastic distortion of the truth it would
be you uh Turley fail to get done what
you promised dozens if not hundreds of
times and you managed to convince
Democrats to give you a couple of things
well I think this tactic of just
repealing Obamacare could actually work
for them because then you still get
those votes from the very right wing of
the party that Ted Cruz's the Mike
leaves and you can afford to lose to
moderates and then in that vacuum when
there's a two-year transition period you
can appeal to
Kratts because they'll be guilted into
it because everyone will realize that
pretty much any alternative is going to
be better than the pre Affordable Care
Act era sure once you make the new
status quo Obamacare is gone and
potentially 32 million people lose care
then you create much more of an impetus
to actually do something and Trump has
been pushing that vote on a repeal only
narrative I told you about his tweet a
few weeks ago he also tweeted about this
last night Donald Trump tweeting
Republicans should just repeal failing
Obamacare now and work on a new health
care plan that will start from a clean
slate Dems will join in that was
yesterday
previously Donald Trump saying or
actually no this was earlier today as I
have always said let Obamacare fail and
then come together to do a great health
care plan stay tuned this could be a
blessing in disguise for Trump and
Republicans because obviously health
care wise it's good to keep Obamacare if
the alternative was the AHCA but
politically it's less likely that
Republicans will be damaged from failing
to keep this promise then the damage
they might suffer if 22 million people
lose lose coverage so even though it's a
loss from a political perspective it
might actually be a blessing in disguise
for Republicans not one that I'm
cheering by the way just pointing it out
it's very very hard to take entitlements
away from people I mean maybe there was
initially some opposition to the
Affordable Care Act but now that it's
been implemented for seven years and
people rely on it
good luck taking that away from people
in rural areas across the country there
is HR 676 the expanded Medicare for all
bill it was up proposed by House
Democrats in January it's available I'm
just saying the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership